unnecessary death why a mockumentary
about suicide we shot the necessary
death in 2004 so that was before the big
wave
documentary and we just came on a film
school it's often hunting or some
talking friendship aside my editor we
have done all our student films together
so we wanted to shoot it out first
teacher write up the for school we don't
want to wait because a lot of people you
know kind of providing they're
developing fundraising and are always
hoping that someone will give them
million suddenly to shoot that Phil
would you want to fall into that trap to
never shoot anything again because we
were develop
for eight to ten years in which upon to
go go go and we didn't have script and
we did have an
this really smart idea to shoot it in
the fake documentary style and not light
anything
you know just got a really cheap camera
but one of our actors have just borrowed
that
and just start shooting you know just to
keep the momentum up and they develop
the story while we were children so
that's where we start up in front
we kind of engineered it backwards that
we were first saying what do with access
to what can we shoot that is not going
to achieve so than we needed we had our
stock and that we need a story that
would actually fit in with that style so
we couldn't really shoot in outer space
or western or some period piece you know
so that kind of defined the story
what is it about suicide such a taboo
topic to some people that maybe has been
a little more trendy now Sochi light of
bullying and all that what was it about
suicide that you wanted to explore I
think was necessary death to me is not
even so much about suicides more about
the ambition of the people that follow
the suicide of a guy you know if he
wants to make a movie that
really focuses on the issue of suicide I
think he would take someone he was
making
the choice of dozens have a branch in
our case the guy we're following has a
brain tumor it's going to die anyway we
did that on purpose so that we wouldn't
actually get into the whole
philosophical moral ethical issues so
much that we could because they would
have to shoot a 10-hour movie do
something to kind of explore that into
their justice but we wanted to explore
the ambition of the filmmaker and in
order to do that I think you have to
deal in our case we wanted to deal with
a life-and-death situation you know so
it wasn't so much the fascination with
suicide rather than someone who is
facing that dilemma and is so vulnerable
you know because you can manipulate and
ask the filmmaker as the documentarian
you can manipulate them into the one
direction or the other direction
the documentary team mentioned falling
apart and going go to war with each
other that was kind of powerful but it
just was important that the stakes were
high enough that suicide worked well
I want to read a part of your article on
tone courage calm and you mentioned I
had been invited to sit on the jury of
the skeena up festival in Kosovo and
some of the most incredible days of my
life so happy at times and one of the
evenings have been set aside for the
jury members to screen their projects
you write my colleagues films had been
met with standing ovations and I am of
course ready for mine the last shot fade
to black
and nothing complete silence and then
what happens
well I got up because I was gonna do the
QA and
I just couldn't understand why there was
complete silence you know I just didn't
processes in that moment him walking
down the stairs and it's still dark and
I'm hearing from underneath me and then
looking down if there's a girl who's
actually lying in the aisle and she's
twitching and she's crying and her her
neighbor the guy was sitting next to her
met his and his face and his hands and
was rocking back and forth like this and
the tears were running down his forearms
you know and I'm turning around and it
was just a weird atmosphere in the room
because you'd have a feeling for how an
audience moves after a movie you know
there's the steady flow to the exit and
it was completely the opposite people
were walking into all the directions and
they were either too fast or too slow
and was just weird and I'm looking
around and there are these aisles babies
decisional Islands people that are
gathering around their friends and
pulling them to their feet and talking
to them and it was calm
emergency situation and that's when I
realized they didn't understand that it
wasn't a real document they thought we
had just killed someone on screen that
they have been falling in love with over
90 minutes and then we killed him off
you know they were reacting to that and
I was running around just about doing
first aid and I was telling people this
was not real they were activists the guy
who killed himself was an actor and they
were so I think they were so not
grasping it but even when I said that
one girl she was crying and she said he
was an actor did the documentarian know
and I was like no the documentarian was
an actor too you know everyone you saw
on the on the screen was but they were
just so impacted by that experience and
I always thought if you can evoke
emotions that's strong from an audience
that alone is a great thing I was kind
of waiting for my Oscar I was like isn't
this great
yeah and they didn't think it was great
you know and they all had the same
question they were all asking why what
what are you trying to do why did you do
this
you know wasn't have had dropped this
bomb on this audience and now they
wanted to know what they should have
learned and what they were supposed to
take away from it and I didn't have an
answer and it was the worst feeling in
the world
you know because I was kind of
responsible for and there was no glory
in there you know I had never actually
thought that through and I called the
rest of the team in Los Angeles and said
we have to recut this movie until 12:00
and what just happened and they need to
get it they said isn't that what we've
been working on for four years you know
to create an experience that is so
authentic and feels so real that you
actually fall for it and I said but
that's not enough we need this answer
which I would never have believed before
I saw that scene I would always have
thought it's enough to create emotional
turmoil and let the audience figure out
those questions themselves you know I
don't have to give the answers and this
whole elders responsibility and
filmmaking
pseudo-intellectual blah blah but when I
saw that in action how much they were
need often answer in a head of closure
somehow that I couldn't provide it just
didn't feel good and then we did we cut
the ending and interesting enough we we
had an alternative ending and after
often ending that we have shot already
where one more person dies their
beginning that we have in the movie
right now without giving anything away
but two people that instead of one and
for some reason the audience seems to be
much more okay with that because there
are some feeling of justice you know the
bad guy the guy that had manipulated
person a into soon as that now was
getting some kind of punishment
and suddenly it didn't weigh so heavily
what the audience couldn't deal with her
surfers the sky that they love that he's
being manipulated
killing himself and he kills himself in
the movies all they needed that little
bit of artifice that little bit of
Hollywood twist ending oh it's like a
hole right before he dies actually
standing up for himself and for the
woman that he loves one last time and
actually commits this hopper rhythmic
act yeah but he's not just simple victim
down much better with the almond so we
got a team that down
you